i just came back from you know three
weeks in eastern europe
and i'll tell you one thing like you can
say what you what you like about eastern
european countries and
yeah a little bit corrupt a bit more
dangerous maybe but
they're at least they all share a
similar value system
and because of that there is still
ingrained shame
in those cultures like romania and
ukraine where i was hanging out
women aren't running around acting like
[ __ ] for the most part because they
still fear their father
they still fear their father they
respect their father that's for damn
sure
like there's i would also say that comes
from that comes from a cult
a unified cultural set of values that
everybody agrees upon yeah and i'll tell
you what else it
uh prompts is investment in that culture
when you have a culture that you're
proud of or you're vested in
not only will you avoid the wrong
actions to insult that culture
you'll probably invest that and and i
can't emphasize it enough and john i've
been thinking about this
but god you go to walmart and your eyes
are getting
assaulted by all the fat ugly people not
just women but
men too and they're dressed for [ __ ] and
then sterling you and
who's the other guy with the british
accent that nobody likes and looks like
uh
daniel craig who is that guy troy yeah
that guy yeah yeah
i'm kidding i'm kidding but you guys
went to russia and uh
it yeah it's a different culture but the
girls are fit and you get to look it's
like oh my god
and um even coach red pill i don't know
how much you guys watch him or
what side of the fence we're on but he
did a video about the difference between
eastern european women
and uh western women and he's talking
about how there is no welfare state and
by by society by force they have to stay
in shape and find a guy if they don't
have kids i think we used to have
culture in the us i think we had a
culture we had a work hard you achieve
you build up
and we didn't have this kind of [ __ ]
culture before because like
the people coming in latin americans
people
from other places they they're they're
not
you know that type of leftist type
mentality but like in the last
30 years or so since like the 70s a lot
of our problems i think
started kind of in the 70s you guys
started changing
you know we started losing that identity
of like anybody can work hard and
achieve
that like you know we had family units
the african-american families got broken
up
we incentivized single motherhood and
rewarded bad
decisions bad behavior by a lot of
people and um
putting a lot of people into debt so i
think we've lost
a lot of what the american culture was
well and i think i think it's because
america and the west in general adopted
this
attitude of every culture is equal
and everybody's like life experience is
equally valid
that was the that's the problem that we
adopted like and what kind of values are
those sterling are those masculine
values are feminine
[Laughter]
what is this idea that like oh you could
be a total fuck-up
and we're still gonna like accept you
and and
tell you that you're just valuable yeah
no judgment no shame right
and that's obviously not worked because
of where we're at
it's getting it's going to get worse too
what it all boils down to is i'm i'm
surprised the money man didn't speak up
not aaron he has no money uh rich
that if you pay a look if you pay
attention to
what really this this culture has become
the culture has been molded by
corporations
that's all it's been down to feminism is
not about empowering women
anytime you look at some sort of
feminist organization it is always tied
back to
extracting money or votes
out of women period there's no ands ifs
or buts about it look at the
look at the organic black lives matter
movement right it was really about black
people getting killed
by police unfairly incarcerated unfairly
right
who came in the feminists the feminists
and the alphabet mafia came in and were
like hey like black lives matter don't
forget to put on this rainbow [ __ ]
and uh you know that they made it
political
um looking at all of the things that are
happening now in the culture right
it's more profitable to split men and
women up you can tax them both equally
you can have one person paying rent here
and one person paying rent over there
two different electricity bills it's
just easier to divide and conquer
and the basis of life
is for men and women to be together
support each other
have children and work together in
harmony and we're we've strayed away
from that in america and that's why it's
like
if you look at america like everybody's
just like this it's this corporate
consumerism culture and everybody's like
miserable
like people are happy over in japan
where i'm at like when i was walking
around america i just see like
just miserable people like the people
like people are casually
miserable well that's the other title
that you'll see if you do the search is
modern women are
miserable today and unhappy and you know
that sort of stuff
that i enjoy you guys let me ask a
question to the panel
uh because we have three people who
aren't americans
uh but did you guys in the late 80s and
early 90s have it
where people made fun of leave it to
beaver you guys all know the show right
yeah sterling you never heard rach you
never heard of leave it to beaver no i
watched leave it to you
when i was a kid okay all right so but
you and i remember it was very
fashionable like oh what you think on
june oh look how square they are and
here's like this perfectly functional
albeit fictional uh nuclear family
and i just remember them making so much
fun especially
what do you think of june cleaver and
when i was like no but
what's wrong with that and now how many
girls would kill
to have a ward cleaver upper middle
income good looking guy
uh shows up on time raises his kids
they'd kill to have a ward cleaver today
i'll tell you what that was replaced
with because
because the next sitcom that came after
that that became even more popular was
the brady bunch
which basically facilitated cuckoldry
right
won those two families together have 17
children live at the same freaking house
and then make a show out of it
and you know we'll call this a new
normal and that and that you know
of course you know towed the line with i
don't need no man or if this marriage
ain't working out i can just get
divorced and
we'll just blend families with some new
guy who's you know potentially going to
be better off
money to have a he's got three sons and
a live-in maid
that decides to marry somebody with
three kids
and then now what do you have you have
that new show on netflix
sex life right which is hilarious if you
just look at like you have this chick
who's been ran through in her past right
so she's been completely ran through
post wall
somehow she's able to score like the
most perfect
good looking husband guy he has money
he's good-looking he's shredded wherever
and she decides oh but i just can't
forget like this chad that was in my
past so
i'm gonna ruin my family to go get dick
down and like that
that that show if you just so you know
is blowing up on netflix right now it is
massively popular
and that's look and people are dumb so
you watch that kind of stuff
they're gonna run that past their brain
and that they're gonna they're gonna
recreate that stuff
i mean what you consume is what you
become a big part of american culture
like i'm sorry but america has become
way more ratchet and ghetto lately too
it's just disgusting because you're
you're looking at
people like i hate cardi b right i think
cardi b
like cardi b is supposed to be she's
supposed to be a role model she's a
former stripper
that used to drug men and robbed them do
you understand bill cosby
if we used to drug if any of us on this
panel drugged women
and robbed them we'd be all of us would
be we'd be crucified
but this woman celebrated and she's
celebrated because
that's what the media wants and makes
money i noticed they had her as a cameo
in
fast nine why would you go see that
movie
great movie actually probably one of the
last
masculine male leads out there that
wow you can watch from hollywood they
call that they call that series in
in japan you know what they call that
series fast and furious
call it wild speed it's a wild
a really good name i like that
you